Night of being photographed
shirtless and alongside wild animals,
rabbits.
At the same time,
Vladimir Putin,
he's cultivated an image
as an intimidating and
fearless figure on the world
stage.
He's a martial arts expert,
but fearless political actor and a former
spy is resume holds a certain cachet
in the west.
As a former KGB agents,
he's automatically
associated with secrecy,
intimidation,
and the old fears Americans had of the
Soviet Union for much of the 21st century
policing instead of himself that he
lives in long time as an ordinary person,
ordinary Ms. all he
wishes to be for decades,
though he hasn't been anything but
ordinary as he spent his life climbing the
ranks of the Russian government's
moving farther and farther away from his
ordinary roots.
He was born in Saint Petersburg in
1957 in the midst of the Cold War.
Putin,
he had two older brothers,
but unfortunately both
died during childhood,
so Puson,
he was raised essentially
as an only child.
He was an atheist as a child,
but today he's an eastern
Orthodox Christian.
During Putin's childhood,
his mother stayed at home and his father,
a veteran of world war two,
worked in a factory as an
interesting aside here,
his grandfather was a cook.
He works for Vladimir Lenin and even
prepared meals for stolen a few times the
pigeon family.
They lived in a communal apartment
shared by three families,
a home where Putin says he used
to hunt rats in the stairwell.
Perhaps a precursor to you is later
fascination with hunting Manz with wild
animals in general.
No,
no.
Growing up,
it didn't prove himself to be anything
particularly special in his early years,
but then by the age of 12 he
discovered athletic competition.
It was in the midst of a competition
that Putin began to set himself apart.
Martial arts was his chosen sport,
particularly sambo and judo.
Though his mother did not
initially approve of his
participation in these sports
boots and proved himself to be a
worthy and skilled competitor in both.
At one point,
his coach even showed up at the pigs and
home to speak with his mother about how
much promise that image showed.
Well,
I was actually that the did the trick
and his parents began to support his
athletic pursuits.
These in now holds a black belt in judo
and just continued to compete in both
sambo and judo,
establishing himself as the first world
leader to be at an advanced level in
these sports.
He also remains the presidents at the
same Dojo he practiced in while growing up
though he established himself
as athletically talented person,
did not excel academically in
school during his challenges.
He attended a local school for his early
years and then attended a magnet school
focused on chemistry.
He didn't push himself,
but his teacher saw that he did have
potential and they encouraged him to focus
as much on his school work as he
did on his martial arts practice.
It was in the sixth grade when really
began to push himself and that showed in
his grades.
He was welcomed to the Young Pioneers,
the youth group that was
run by the Communist Party.
This was a serious mark of honor is pizza
and had previously been one of only a
few from the class who had
not been welcomed into the
organization now from 1970
to 1975 feet in,
continued his studies at some
Petersburg State University.
While there he studied law and was
required to join the communist party.
He later left the posse
denouncing communism in 1991.
When he said of Marxism Leninism this,
it became more and more obvious for me,
more obvious that it was nothing more
than a beautiful and harmful fairytale in
Petersburg state university pten.
Matt's Anatoly Sobchak who would become
a key figure in Putin's political
success.
Self check was an assistant
professor at the school,
but he actually went on to co author the
constitution of the Russian Federation
and was also the first democratically
elected mayor of some Peter's though.
Okay.
Who's in graduated from Saint Petersburg
State University in 1975 and it was
then that he joined the KGB.
KGB was the Soviet Union Security
Agency for much of the 20th century.
It was created in 1954 and continued to
operate until 1991 when the Soviet Union
itself was dismantles.
It translated to English.
KGB stands for state security committee.
It has a reputation for oppression and
monitoring the actions and opinions of
Soviet citizens.
KGB.
It was a truly frightening organization
for democracy as an indication of the
dangers of communism to Westerners,
the organization rebellions and kept a
close eye on anyone suspected to be an
opposition to the Soviet regime who
didn't started his career with the KGB in
Leningrad boss.
He was a to move to do Dresden,
Germany before was transferred to Germany.
Putin married to this very day.
Putin keeps his home life are very private
and information about his family is
very closely guarded.
He and his wife lived.
Millard were married from 1983
until the divorce in 2013,
that divorce that was seemingly amicable
with no specific reason given for it
though Lynn Miller made references to
Putin's dedication to his work and the
time investment required
to serve as a world leader.
They have two daughters together,
Maria and tax arena,
both of whose lives
remain incredibly secrets.
They both used fake names to go and
register for college and it's not entirely
known in which country either of the
daughters currently lives in 2016 European
newspapers even described and Maria as a
secret daughter noticing if she had not
been willing to be photographed during
the entire length of Putin's time and
power for a former spy
and they man with many,
many enemies.
It's sensible that his daughters have
maintains this secret life who didn't
indeed a status either private life
in which I do not permit interference.
It must be respected,
so pretend he moved with his family to
Dresden where he served
with the KGB for five years.
He was fluent in German and still
speaks this language to this day.
Auntie stated that he actually feels more
comfortable using German than English.
Putin served in this dresden
posts from 1985 to 1990,
working as an undercover agents
playing the part of a translator.
The work,
though not all of our
peers in the dead is known.
It was the spy after all,
it wasn't particularly interesting.
Much of it was simply amassing
information on people,
ensuring that they remain
loyal to the Soviet.
Some we're not passing
any kind of revolution.
In 1999,
though the situation it became rather
than more dicey for Soviet see were
stationed in Dresden during one incident
as it became more and more clear that
he's German,
he was falling out of Soviet control.
Putin and his colleagues feared for
their lives as crowds stormed the KGB
headquarters in Dresden.
Booty calls in the Soviet
military for how the birds.
He was told that nothing could be done
for them and less Moscow gave the order
something that Moscow never did.
While Putin and his colleagues well,
they survived that day,
it has become increasingly clear that
the situation was unstable during this
time.
Putin ends of the KGB.
Agents began burning files so that when
the day came that their headquarters was
either taken or abandons or both,
no files would be left in
the hands of the enemy.
The Berlin Wall fell in November of 1989
and soon after Peyton and his family,
they returned to Russia by
this point piece in held.
The rank of lieutenant
colonel indicates beat,
however the KGB was nearing the end of
its existence and Putin was able to find
work at the State
University of some pieces.
Doug.
He was no ordinary professor.
They ate.
He was still working for the KGB,
part of his job included keeping an eye
out for students who showed promise as
potential new kgb
recruits through his job,
but he was also able to reconnect
with his former professor and Natalie.
Subject.
Subject,
he was elected the mayor of Pittsburgh
in 1991 and Putin joined his team as an
advisor.
He works for subject until 1996 when
subject last reelection losing could've
opted to continue working
for his successor,
but Putin believes that taking a job with
subjects political opponents would be
disloyal.
Anti.
Instead chose to move to Moscow to begin
working with the Yeltsin administrator.
During Boris Yeltsin presidency,
pten rose through the ranks first serving
as deputy chief administrative or the
Kremlin.
Russia is fashion of
the White House in 1999,
he was named secretary of the Security
Council and became Yeltsin's chief
advisor on matters of foreign
relations and intelligence,
but it was then the Putin's
Korea got a real real boost.
Yeltsin decided he didn't want to
keep his current prime minister,
so he got rid of him.
That was in August of 1999 and oh,
he was the beneficiary of this decision
as the eldest son named Vladimir Putin
and do the post Yeltsin offered Putin
the position of a prime minister with
prospects somewhat foreshadowing the
next step in Putin's Korea because it was
only months after naming buton is
prime minister Boris Yeltsin himself.
Steps down and Vladimir Putin became the
acting president of Russia and that was
in December of 1999.
Then three months later,
in March of 2015,
he was officially elected and became
president of Russia in his own
right.
10 opponents run against
him for president,
but he won nationals for the
first time in Russia's history.
There was a peaceful transfer of power
to a democratically elected presidents
who didn't.
He used his first time to advocate for
certain international policies including
approval of the start,
two arms treaty and improving relations
with China was also initially supportive
of the United States,
his war on terror that fully the
nine slash 11 terrorist attacks,
but he did not support the United States.
This invasion of Iraq during Putin's first
summer in power tragedy struck Russia
when the cask submarine sank
in the barren sea in August.
Please didn't.
He was on vacation when the sinking
your courage and he did not immediately
returned home to address the sinking and
the deaths of all 118 crew members who
had been on board.
Then when he was asked what
went wrong with the cask,
Putin replied starkly that
it sank destroyers and angry
Russians were attacking
the president for his handling or like
they're all over the cask disaster with
some even accusing him of leaving sailors
to die when a rescue might've still
been possible.
That despite all of this opinion,
polls showed that overall his image
did not sustain much damage from the
tragedy.
Indeed,
four years later,
the cask tragedy did not
affect his reelection.
At all in 2004,
the Russians reelected him to
a second term as president,
and they were apparently
really pleased with the job.
He was doing his speech and received
over 70 percent of the volume
during his first term in office who's
head focused on economic reform,
having denounced communism.
He instead supported an economic system
that was essentially capitalism with
very strict regulations and oversight.
After years of economic struggle,
Russia was finally beginning to see a
stabilizing and even growing economy under
Putin.
Some reports,
but Russia's grief during his first
term at seven percent annually.
Indeed,
he still remembered
favorably for this growth,
though it came with increased
nationalization of industry
and in part because of
the mid two thousands,
global financial crash,
the grief did not last,
but in the country.
He's economy was in disarray for
nearly the entire decade before pten.
His rise to power and area of growth in
which disposable income nearly doubles
was reason for the people to think
really positively of Pearson.
Now Pearson did work on those economic
policies we already mentioned is fast
done,
but he also made strides in foreign
relations including making a historic trip
to Israel.
This was the first ever trip by
a Russian leader to the country.
Conversations between Putin and Israeli,
focused largely on security issues.
The tread gotten as much attention to
around the world as it came in the midst
of strengthening ties
between Russia and Israel.
Though the two nations disagreed on topics
such as the Russian side of missiles
to Syria,
the trip was also seen as a move by Putin
to help secure Russia's position as a
key diplomatic actor in any Middle
East peace discussions or agreements.
Now,
security issues were
present not just abroad,
though then homeland security would
become a major focus for Putin.
Unfortunately,
this is something that became really
clear during the horrific tragedy of the
Beslan school.
In 2014 in September,
terrorists held over 1000 people hostage
at the Beslan school in North Asitia.
Nearly 800 of these hostages.
They were children for three days.
These terrorists demolishing Chechen,
an independence from Russia helped these
people hostage situation had a tragic
ending when tanks,
rockets,
and other artillery we used by the Russian
military to try to clear the school.
Special Forces entered the school after
hearing explosions from inside were the
hostages were being caps,
but their actions,
they did not save lives.
Quite the contrary in the
siege of the school ever.
300 people died,
nearly two thirds of whom
were children the tragedy.
It shook the world,
and while the government's
was cleared of any wrongdoing,
initially,
the European Court of human rights later
stated that Russia had used excessive
force and lacked caution,
and they storm into the school just
bawling his anger and discontentment that
the government's handling
of the tragedy in general,
it did not affect the public's view
of pewter and very much at all,
quite the opposite.
In fact,
a poll taken off to the
best of a masochist stated
that 83 percent of Russians
were still happy with him.
The vessel and tragedy did lead to
changes in the halls of Russian power,
though primarily giving more
power to the Russian president.
For instance,
instead of electing governors in
regions like north Asitia in Chechnya,
the presidents would have the power
to appoint governance in 2007,
and during his second term,
Putin was named Time
Magazine's person of the year.
The magazine called the final year of
his second term is most successful yet,
and it's the cover photo for the issue,
a portrait of Putin,
one the photographer,
the world press photo award.
During the shoot that
you've discussed them,
mutual admiration for the Beatles.
This connection helped you tend to
become more comfortable and it's for the
photographer,
the chance to get an award winning
shot of the intimidating world leader.
No matter how popular Putin was,
though that Russian people could not
elect him to a third time the Russian
constitution simply for credit.
However,
pieces and found a way around this role
just when his time in office was about
to years
run out.
Presidential terms in Russia
had been extended to six years,
but this change did not benefit Putin.
He was beholding to the
previous constitutional rules.
So how is it you got to stay in
power while the man who was elected,
Russia's next presidents
was Dimitri Medvedev,
and he was a protege of Putin's and
benefited from Putin's rise to power.
Neither he nor I wanted Putin's it'd be
pushed off the international stage and
so medvedev unnamed Putin
as Russia's prime minister,
a position he had previously held
under Boris Yeltsin after 13 years in
leadership at present would remain
as the highest levels of Russia's
governments.
He and his supporters were able to keep
them in power and stay in line with the
law,
although not exactly in
line with its exact intent.
During his third time as prime
minister from 2008 to 2012,
Putin focused on dealing with the economic
crisis that swept the wells as well
as Russia's population problems.
Russia is population was falling
by 1 million people a year,
a devastating number for a country
whose population is only $150 million in
2010.
The trend is reversed and
Russia's population began to grow.
The reversal is empowered credited
to Putin's economic reforms.
When people have more money,
it is easier to support a larger family.
One of Putin's economic reforms include
in joining the World Trade Organization
or WTO in 2012 negotiations
for rushing to join.
The WTO lasted nearly two
decades as they had started.
After the fall of the Soviet Union,
Russia was granted entry into the WTO.
Often negotiations reached a point in
which granted Russia permission to phase
in the opening of markets.
Wireless aligns with other
WTO trading requirements.
Now all his political party
retains dominance and Putin
was again the candidate
for president in 2012.
He did not escape politically unscathed
from his maneuver to hold onto power
buying.
Sidestepping the term limits the elections
in 2012 for that heavily protested
with claims of fraud tainting
Putin's election to a third time.
The task,
if the government is not only
to pour honey into a cup,
but sometimes do you give it
a medicine bottle display?
Those protests?
Well,
he was inaugurated in May of 2012,
and this time his term would be six years.
This means that Putin will be president
of Russia until at least 2018 and with
allegations of his interference in the
United States elections is prominence in
the world.
My only turn you seems to road
wheaton has continued to be reelected,
reappointed to positions at the highest
level of Russian government's his time
in office.
It's not been without questions
surrounding his shady actions.
Among the high points or
low points we should say,
of intrigue surrounding Poussin.
All the murders of Russian journalists,
that's of generalists were any
points of concern in Russia.
Longed for Putin's rise to power,
but the issue well,
it began to get a lot of international
attention during Putin's second time as
presidents when journalists,
a political sky was murdered.
This journalist had been a strong critic
of Putin and particularly the war in
Chechnya.
Even before her death,
she was even poisoned but
ultimately recovered her mother.
It remains to this day on solved,
but there is suspicion that
Putin and his governance,
well maybe they targeted taught well.
Let's.
Sky is also far from the
only Putin opponents.
His death has occurred in suspicious
circumstances in March of 2017.
The Washington Post even published a
list of 10 such deaths among deaths was a
former deputy prime minister and Putin
critic who was shot outside the Kremlin.
He was a tycoon and his death
was initially called a suicide,
but now that's rather unsure is also a
generalist who was kidnapped and shot in
the woods and the former KGB agent.
He was found to be
poisoned by Russian agents.
Then there's the generalist who died of
a mysterious illness and he's medical
records have been sealed.
Sajan not failing on any intriguing.
Yeah,
I get many of these deaths may never be
proven beyond doubt to be the work of
Putin's government.
One thing is absolutely certain Vladimir
Putin does not like to be viewed as
weak.
He has done all he can to prevent strength
and show the world that he is strong
and manly.
Beyond is active
participation in martial arts.
He shows his power and
dominance by hunting,
tracking,
and closing with wild animals.
He's caught a huge fish including a
46 pounds pike and shot a crossbow.
At a whale,
normally to tranquilize it though,
you also want to save to camera crew
from a Siberian tiger that was about to
attack them while on a tour
of a wildlife sanctuary.
Further,
he's actually got close
enough to hold a bas.
Do you attach a tracking device
to them for a research project?
Now,
polar bears might look cute in your mind.
I think this is particularly dangerous,
but they're actually
incredibly vicious creatures.
Susan is also attached
himself to an experiment,
so flying machine to accompany
birds on my graduation,
and it's important to note that he
always does these things carefully,
making sure that that
photographer is presence.
The more I know about people,
the more I like dogs.
I like simple animals.
What?
He's not hanging out with wild
animals who didn't make time for other
adventurous and athletic activities.
He dives into black seed
and explores shipwrecks,
plays hockey.
You ride snowmobiles and motorcycles,
and does even driven a Formula One
racecar once during a visit to a Russian
youth camp.
Even challenged attendees to arm wrestle
with him then nor contends with arm
wrestling as a show of strength.
He trying to bend a frying
pan with his bare hands.
Naturally though
photography his own hands,
you capture all of these incredible
moments and the photos have been
distributed,
widely viewed around the world.
You've probably seen several of them
from his days at school cultivating an
athletic reputation to his
time as president and Prime
Minister Putin has made
it known that he isn't
mad to be recognized
during this most recent time as
president with a couple of years left go,
Putin has found himself
centered on the world stage.
Russia has been involved
in the Syrian civil war,
supporting the governments of Bashar al.
Al sat in early july of 2017,
vladimir putin and Donald Trump announced
a ceasefire in southwestern Syria and
weeks later Russia announced that it
had signed a deal with Syria allowing
Russia to keep it sad base in the country
for at least 50 more years in addition
to Syria.
PerhAps putin's most talked
about involvement haS been
the alleged interference
of Russia in the u.
S election from hacking allegations do
you questions of elicit meetings and
deals with members of
trump's inner circle.
The u s ends the wells media.
I've made putin and
his political dealings,
a household conversation topic,
so let them be opposing.
It began his life growing up in a
communal apartments in the midst of Russia
during the cold war,
and that's become an
internationally polarizing figure.
He's been strong and unapologetic in
his foreign policy and use of force and
questions while they're around his
treatments of political opponents and
critical Journalists.
Putin,
he's unwilling to sit back,
be a shrinking violet on the world stage,
ensuring Russia remains a world
power with a great deal of influence.
He has done overtly,
can't cultivate an image of strength
both for Russia as a country and for
himself personally,
showing no signs of stopping
is adventurous and dad
have a lifestyle even as he
enters his sixties.
Vladimir putin,
he has undoubtedly made a
place for himself in world
history and within eligible
for reelection in 2018.
We may still have many years of
putin on the world stage ahead of us,
so I hope you liked the video.
If you didn't know what to do
that funds our button below,
don't forget to subscribe below.
We put our brand new videos twice a week,
so subscribe for more
things just like this,
if you did like them.
Also oVer there on the right,
couple of other videos that you might
like to check out if you enjoyed this one,
and as always,
thank you for watching.